if you were gonna give another
screenwriter a pep talk let's say they
were coming to story Expo 2015 and maybe
they were nervous we heard from a couple
of people that there were some people
that were nervous right well would your
pep talk be to that screenwriter don't
be nervous okay
it's it first of all it doesn't serve
anything I mean maybe it does it helps
you prepare maybe well nervous had
better prepare so you're prepared but
you can prepare without being nervous so
nervous has nothing to do with it but I
find that I've always been right
artistically maybe not among other
people but artistically I've always been
right maybe I didn't have enough chops
so keep writing or keep drawing you know
I've got paint also but but keep keep
doing it and always try to be better and
always try to do your best but don't
listen to other people well I guess you
can listen but you're not to do what
they say and that's I guess the
difference you know listen I've always
been right and I found out every other
person has always been right who's been
successful successful people are right a
priori one of the great things about
about pitching my rehearsal back at home
was I said okay what's the core of the
clown what's the core of the clown and
that I had to go what's the core of
Chaplin what's the core of any clown no
doubt clowns have no doubt that's why
they're funny I mean they hit a
challenge and they they hit a wall they
get stopped but they don't they don't
Chaplin once he stopped just goes in
another direction but he doesn't back up
and go God you know they they they get
over they get over they don't get over
it they get over it keep going forward i
remote tarantino said some of the most
brilliant thing you know directory he
said well hey you know how do you just
keep going he says I think of myself as
a pac-man you know that game pac-man
he said I think of myself as a pack man
I can't go back I can only go forward
any huge bites cool Thank You mr.
Tarantino so that I just keep that in
mind there's no doubt man you just keep
going you and and maybe you're not good
enough now for this but as long as you
get better just keep on going that
that's all so you know I learned I'm not
saying you can't learn that's why I'm
here to learn how to pitch you know but
there was never a time when someone just
crushed you oh yeah all the time my
parents close friends I mean everybody
yes they did I and then that was that
was the tragedy I listened to these
stupid people I remember a therapist
once said I was complaining about my
father and he first of all he the first
thing he said was I said God what he
said that parents tell their kids
is unbelievable he said every kid that
comes in here
he said they're fine it's their parents
that are crazy but I can't tell
them that because I'll stop taking the
kid a year so you know the best I can do
is protect the kid from who from their
parents it's the parents who up
kids kids don't themselves up
you're born cool you know and then
Slayers come around you so you know
chose not to listen obviously after a
while I learned because I tried to do it
their way I try to do it my parents when
I tried to do my teachers way of trying
to do it everybody else's way and it
never worked so I thought hey let me try
it my way and I found out AI was a lot
happier and gradually I became better
and more affirmed the world affirmed you
know throw that one hand up in the
universe slaps it
you know but that takes a lot of
learning it's not easy
you